à l'heure des choix d'avant-match ce
supporters optent pour le match nul à
l'heure des spectacles d'ouverture le
stade de france n'a pas eu ses géants
mais simplement une cérémonie de mise en
forme ronde si possible carette pelouse
pour ces rase-mottes le tapis vert entre
dans la danse en 380 morceaux pour
commencer des petit bout de jardin pour
footballeur en herbe qui laissons la
place à celle ans met au rebond
capricieux
et puis le ballon reprendra ses droits
sortis d'une fleur le football commence
sérieusement à prendre sa place dans le
tapage et la percussion de supporters à
hyéres aux couleurs des 32 pays
participants
enfin les ballons prennent possession du
ciel quelques minutes avant que les
joueurs occupent le terrain le reste
sera protocolaire l'ouverture de la 16e
coupe du monde c'est déjà du passé
le jouer à pau 2
marquez a surtout